[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ستندمون عاجلا ام اجلا وزتاتون الى بابنا
للتفاوض هكذا قالت موسكو الروس يضاعفون
اسطولهم البحري وفرنسا والمانيا تعترفان
لابد على زلنسكي من التفاوض مع بوتين
لانهاء هذه الغرب الدبابات تتدفق الى
اوكرانيا والهند تعلن عن مواجهه الدب
الروسي فما كل هذه الفوضى بايدن يرفض
المبادره الصينيه والغرب يعلن انسحاب
قواتك من بخبوت فما هو التالي رعب امريكي
من سلاح صيني قد يغير مجرى الحرب
الاوكرانيه والاوروبيون يتجهون نحو الصين
لحل ازماتهم والولايات المتحده تعلن رسميا
عن مواجهات مباشره مع بكين فوق الاجواء
الصينيه وفي المكسيك تاجر مخدرات برتبه
وزير وايران تمد السوريه بسلاح قاتل
الاسرائيلي
الضربات الروسيه تتوالى نشوه الهجمات
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه لا تنتهي
ومن جديد صفارات الانذار تدوي في جميع
المدن الاوكرانيه ونيران المعارك تصرخ هل
من مزيد نعم القوات الروسيه تكثف ضرباتها
وهجماتها على مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في
عموم البلاد لي تؤكد قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قواتها صدت اكثر من 70
هجوما روسيا على عده محاور خلال ساعات عده
لتاتي المفاجاه الروسيه من البحر هذه
المره حيث صرحت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه تستعد لجني
هجوم صاروخي على اوكرانيا من البحر الاسود
مضيفه ان الفرقه ادمر الماكروف توجهت الى
البحر الاسود وعلى متنها ثمانيه صواريخ
ليضيف الجيش ان روسيا ضعفت عدد السفن
العامله في البحر الاسود متوقعا ان يكون
هذا استعدادا لمزيد من الضربات الصاروخيه
ليعترف مسؤولون غربيون واوكرانيون ان قوات
قد تضطر للانسحاب من بخموت بعد تعمد
الاوكران تقليل من القيمه الاستراتيجيه
للمدينه وذلك بحسب صحيفه التايمز فما كان
من قوات نظام كييفا المتبقيه في باخموت
الا ان نسفت سدا مائيا لاعاقه تقدم الجيش
الروسي وفق وسائل الاعلام الروسيه فما
هكذا تؤكل الكتف ايها الاقران لتنهال
الدبابات الغربيه على اوكرانيا وبعد
المانيا وفنلندا او ما بولندا وكندا ترسل
كل منهما اربع دبابات
فما كل هذا السخاء من البر الى البحر يبسط
الروس سي فخلال عام من الحرب استطاعت
القوات الروسيه السيطره على كامل الشواطئ
بحر ازوف اوكرانيا لتشكل تلك المناطق خطوط
الامداد بين القرم واقليم دومبس لتجد
فرنسا والمانيا الحلال لاوكرانيا حيث نصحت
باريس وبرلين اوكرانيا بضروره الانخراط في
محادثات سلام مع روسيا وسط مخاوف غربيه من
تداعيات استمرار الحرب على حسب صحيفه بولو
وهنا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
يقول ان من يدعمون اوكرانيا سيلجاون
للتفاوض عاجلا ام اجلا من اجل تسويه الوضع
وهو ما يدركه الامريكان ايضا حيث قال
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
تحافظ على خطوط اتصال مع روسيا لمنع رفع
التصيد اذا لماذا ياخذكم الغرور يا هؤلاء
عليكم
الى طاوله السلام وهو اقرب الطرق واسهلها
الا تفهمون وعند ذكر السلام والمفاوضات
تظهر امامنا خطه الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا
لكن هذه الخطه تقف بيت تشكيك والقبول
والرفض فموقف واشنطن يبدو فاترا بين
التردد والرفضه كما هو حال بايدن الذي قال
ان فكره تفاوض الصين على نتائج الحرب في
اوكرانيا غير عقلانيه مضيفا ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يصفق له فكيف يمكن
ان تكون جيده فلا مستفيده من الحرب غير
روسيا على حد قوله وذلك لقناه اي بي سي
نيوز
فرحب ببعض البنود توقف اطلاق النار لكنه
قال ان بلاده التي تدور فيها الحرب هي من
يجب ان تطلق خطه السلام ليطلب زلنسكي
الصين بان تضمن ان تغادر روسيا الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بينما شكرت الجهد الصينيه يجري
السلام واشترطت عدم المساس بالمناطق
الاوكرانيه الاربع التي ضمتها مؤخرا فالى
اين تتجه هذه الحرب والى اين ستصل مبادره
اصحاب العيون الضيقه ليجيب ان اوكرانيا
تنتصر وحدها ولا يمكن لدوله الوقوف
بمفردها امام هذا العدوان حسب تعبيره
ليضيف انه لا يعتقد ان لدى الصين عرضا
حقيقيا لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا ليكشف
انه يخطط للقاء الرئيس الصيني
قريبا لكن رئيس الشيشان رمضان قادر يقول
انه لا فائده من المفاوضات مع كييف لانها
دميه في يد الغرب حسب قوله ليخرج مساعد
وزير الداخليه الاوكراني مصرحا بوتين خسر
ولكننا لم ننتصر بعد انا رايح فين انا
راجع تاني ليضيف نحن تحتاج للكثير من
الاسلحه للانتصار على روسيا مهلا يا صديقي
فقانون الحرب يقول هناك شيئا
[موسيقى]
وان تكون منتصرا او مهزوما فلا يوجد طرف
خاسر وطرف لم ينتظر لننتقل الى حرب
التحالفات وفي تطور لافت لموقف نيودلهي
اكدت الهند على موقف معظم اعضاء مجموعه
العشرين المطالب بضروره انسحاب روسيا
الكامل وغير المشروط من كافه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لا تستغرب من موقف الهند فيعلى
خلاف كبير مع الصين والصين هي حليفه روسيا
الاقرب ليعود هنا بيض ويستبعد ارسال
مقاتله اف 16 لاوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي
اذا واشنطن لا تجرؤ على امداد كييف
بالطائرات لكن هنالك ما يؤرق الامريكان
اكثر ويجعلهم يشعرون بقلق متزايد انه
ارسال باسلحه تتضمن طائره بدون طيار
طالبتها موسكو من بكين قد تغير هذه
الطائره مسار الحرب الاوكرانيه بجانب
ذخيره تحتاجها القوات الروسيه العامله في
الصفوف الاماميه وفق صحيفه
الغرب يلجاون للشرق
الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراخ في اوروبا
والغرب يتجه نحو الشرق لايجاد مخرج لهم
نعم هنا اوروبا تتحرك شرقا بحثا عن حلول
للازمات والحروب التي وقعت على اراضيها
وسعيا لتضييق الخناق اكثر على روسيا
فالرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل يعلن انه سيزر
بكين مطلع ابريل المقبل لبحث سبل وقت
الحرب في اوكرانيا وبناء السلام ليتزامن
ذلك مع زياره مماثله للمستشار الالماني
الى الهند تناولت ملف الطاقه وزياده على
موسكو فهل ينقذ الشرقيون الغرب من تلك
الازمات ومن حرب البقاء الى معارك الفضاء
حيث تندلع مناوشات ومواجهه بين مقاتله
صينيه والطائره استطلاع تابعه للبحريه
الامريكيه فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي ليقول
مسؤولون امريكيون ان هذه المواجهات اصبحت
شبهه واكثر خطوره بحسب صحيفه بولو فهل حان
وقت اندلاع الحرب الكبرى بين المارد
الامريكي والتنين الصيني ولمن ستكون
الغلبه عندها
الاحداث والتطورات بعد تسجيلهم ارضيتين
جديدتين في تركيا جاءت دور على اسطنبول
لتخلي المباني تحسبا بالزلزال بعد انهيار
مفاجئ لطريق في بنديك وزير الامن المكسيكي
السابق يواجه حكما بسجنه بعد ادانته
بتجاره المخدرات السلطه وتجاره المخدرات
معا حاميها حراميها كما يقولون افاد
التلفزيون الرسمي الايراني نظرا ستزود
سوريا بسلاح دفاع جوي بهدف مواجهه اسرائيل
التي تواصل استهداف مواقع سوريه وايرانيه
بشكل دوري مبادره الصين بين رفض وقبول
وتردد فهل تنجح هذه المبادره ام ان لاطراف
الحرب رايا اخر
[موسيقى]